IT'S TIME TO PLAY
WILL SING FOR VOTES.
[APPLAUSE]
NOW THAT THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION IS ONLY 390 DAYS
AWAY -- OH MY GOD, THERE'S
GONNA BE SO MUCH MORE OF THIS
BULL[SHIT]. THE CANDIDATES ARE
LOOKING FOR ANY ADVANTAGE TO
HELP PULL AWAY FROM THE PACK
LIKE INSANE SONGS FROM
PATHOLOGICALLY ENTHUSIASTIC
SUPPORTERS, FOR INSTANCE.
COMEDIANS, I'M GONNA SHOW YOU A
GREAT CLIP, AND
FOR 250 POINTS I WANT YOU TO
TELL ME HOW YOU WOULD INTRODUCE
THESE MUSICIANS.
FIRST OFF, HOW ABOUT AN
ON-THE-NOSE COUNTRY SONG FOR
CONSERVATIVE PRO-LIFER
RICK SANTORUM?
>> THAT SOUNDS LIKE A TOLKIEN
NOVEL.
"THERE WILL BE JUSTICE FOR
THE UNBORN."
RIKI LINDHOME.
>> THEY'D VOTE FOR SANTORUM IF
THEY DIDN'T OPPOSE WOMEN
SUFFRAGE, IT'S TWO GIRLS, ONE
GOD.
[APPLAUSE]
[LAUGHTER]
>> ALL RIGHT.
NEXT UP, THIS BREATHLESS ODE TO
NEW JERSEY'S OWN CHRIS CHRISTIE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> WELCOME BACK TO MTV'S
UNPLUGGED. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
ONCE AGAIN, GENE SIMMONS.
[CROWD CHEERING]
>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
JEWEL'S ESTRANGED MOTHER.
[APPLAUSE]
>> RIKI.
>> PLEASE WELCOME YOU CAN'T SAY
ANYTHING NEGATIVE, IT'S YOUR
DAD'S NEW GIRLFRIEND, JANET.
[APPLAUSE]
[LAUGHTER]
>> AW, DAMN IT, DAD.
"JANET MAKES US LISTEN TO ALL
HER SOFT ROCK POLITICAL JAMS."
RIKI, POINTS.
NEXT UP, I BET YOU GUYS WERE
KINDA LIKE "HEY HILLARY CLINTON,
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU NEED? A RAP."
[LAUGHTER]
>> I'M SORRY, DID HE JUST SAY
HILLARY IS REALLY TIGHT?
RIKI.
>> IN COLLEGE YOU KNEW HIM AS
TODD THE VIRGIN. NOW YOU KNOW
HIM AS VANILLA KILLA...THE
VIRGIN.
[APPLAUSE]
>> "ALRIGHT, THIS NEXT CAT
COMING TO THE STAGE.
THE NEXT YOUNG CAT COMING TO
THE STAGE.
YOU SEEN HIM ON ALL THE SHOWS.
YOU SEEN HIM ON "COMING TO THE
STAGE." YOU SEEN HIM ON TBS.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, DUDE
IS FUNNY, GIVE IT UP REAL BIG
FOR KEITH. LOWE. JENSON.
[APPLAUSE]